relate to the money never slow mo no
sure cuz i'm ted it like a cholo and of
course i make your raining you just
watch ok i got game like eczema club in
the club and a straight turn down I've
been battles like I don't give a [ __ ] do
my thang all eyes on me alright so we
are here with young Sam amen good to see
it so young Sam how old are you exactly
23 23 years old why young Sam wasn't man
that's me man young Sam yeah how long
you been rapping man so long since a
young age like seventh grade yes record
him right in on like likes nothing like
a studio that was nothing like rapping
on the windows computer microphone sock
on the mic just grind in here is that
always been something you want to do
from as long as you remember yeah oh its
interests and music right you know your
23 now how long do you think you know so
say you don't hit super big how long are
you gonna keep rapping are you
everything but up whatever because I
feel like a lot of people are so trying
to be the next big thing but this is
something I love so if I don't be that
next big thing tomorrow I'm still gonna
do it next year cuz I'm just perfecting
my craft you know okay yeah so like
someone like okay 2 Chainz right oh it's
35 can you stick it out to 35 teach
anything that happens yeah I believe I
can what do you think you know to change
is just coming up you know he's 35 he's
been doing this for a long time what do
you think recently has made him just
come up to become popular Oh sticking to
his own style everybody like sets trends
you know like everybody looking for that
new theme
2 chainz had this style what wasn't big
before and now people on it so that's
great yeah had a stick to your style you
know a lot of up and coming rappers they
don't you know traditionally go to
youtube you know those do mixtapes you
know i'll sell it we'll just do
SoundCloud or they'll put it on the
Internet why did you decide it on
YouTube cuz it's like a timeline of my
life like through YouTube people could
see how I progressed and they could see
like Oh young Sam he's not no one-hit
wonder he's been doing music for so long
like they could be a with me like people
from across the world could feel like
they know me just through YouTube do you
remember the first video you ever posted
on YouTube uh I had a freestyle like
just wrap it but I didn't like it yeah
so I deleted it and I'm really sad about
that to this day like why did I delete
that when you first start you know
posted on YouTube did you expect that it
was going to become so popular to be
such a hit that you would be straight on
youtube and i did and i just thought i
was just uploading videos to it like
okay i want to keep track of what i've
been doing somebody's uploaded but
little by little have been getting more
viewing the people been following what
I've been doing all right right do you
follow any like other people on YouTube
where rappers like day store or anyone
like that oh yeah I do fall of some
artists yeah ok cool what do you think
of there like you know their craft on
YouTube do you like do you like a lot of
their stuff yeah for like it's another
style like everybody done a different
style I want to open some styles like
that so I'll follow a lot of different
artists doing things right right you
know you just uploaded a freestyle over
the Trinidad James song yeah hold
everything in that that's like its first
single and just blowing up off of that
single new spouse is a new style it is
that why you think it is blowing up so
much because it is a new style I feel
like because uh he's from Atlanta and
people supporting them like other
artists big artists they supporting them
and these artists grinding you know
mm-hmm do you ever get you know you've
been doing this for so long and all the
central neta James is everywhere off of
one song is that every frustrating you
that one person can just put out one
song all of a sudden the this huge deal
in interviews everywhere
don't frustrate me because it's
different ways to make it to the top you
know some people make it to the top like
that but some people stick on and be
legendary like you know 25 I only got so
many songs jay-z you know James II got
thousands the songs you know so it's
like the road to being legendary so you
know you mentioned Tupac and of course
it always goes back to you know Tupac
being West Coast legend biggie beanie
East Coast legend I was talking to a guy
who was saying that you know Tupac was
good and he had good beats me and good
styling a good personality but Palmer
found to be he was a better rapper you'd
better you know better flow do you agree
what he think I'm west coast always down
with Tupac because the stories he tell
is more related to what people go
through Big E is very lyrical and
talented I respect that when I'm from
you know like to [ __ ] could tell a story
you'll feel like he talking about
somebody your family or you it's like
dang that's how I feel with two pot and
he also could wear a nose ring make it
look really yeah but make it look G I've
never seen anyone make it knows me so
hard life man um so you know which one
it at James you know big boy kind of
came out endorse them and said the trend
ending was true Atlanta and that's huge
cuz big boys like it might you know yeah
is there a West Coast rapper who you
would really want to come on st. your
stuff is real and yourselves real West
Coast man Snoop Dogg for sure something
dog don't have to be snoop yeah well
snoop you know he's he's getting the
YouTube game too did you know that he's
you know he started he signed out he's
on another studios and YouTube maybe
smart man what do you what do you think
his reasoning for wanting to do that is
to start jumping onto YouTube I feel
like being smarter staying on top of his
business and trying to get fans like
like YouTube got so many people like you
know YouTube lets you know like it's
millions of people on YouTube so just
reading that it makes me like oh I gotta
be on youtube I gotta make sure I'm
I love Snoop Dogg for the same way and
he got more access to people so he's
gonna be on everything that happened
access with his fans yeah absolutely you
know snoop even for me a lot of the
times you know he started off really
hard on the case he sounded really
really hard and now is this it's not so
hard does that ever body in a rock that
starts with just really hard gangs
persona and it kind of goes into less
less serious less hard stuff a lot of
people who would say that but like y'all
know what they're going through you know
maybe once like at the beginning of his
career he was going through so much and
ain't now he got what he got like he got
what he wants he's successful so now
he's talking about different things
meeting new people yeah life is changing
you know you changed the name of snow
blind yeah what do you think about that
new fan base new fan days yeah why do
you think I bring a new fan base you got
everybody else yeah so you know on that
same note on facebook i think it was i
was checking on your facebook last night
you see this you had to do a bunch of
community service yes you're gonna go to
Yale keep talking about that at all
community service I need to do that make
sure you're on top of your things but
right now travel for Nia that's what I'm
on that's why like I really want to come
up with this album for my friends and
like I got this damn city car chase ev3
and both of them coming december 19 and
I want to really deliver that to my fans
so I'm like i'ma finish this project and
then i'ma do to my work but you have it
by the end of the year yeah 60 hours you
want to make it happen in about 11 days
sortie think you're gonna do grind yeah
i'ma grind yeah I'm gonna make it happen
so you know you grew up in in south
central yeah how much of growing up in
South Central has affected your music in
effect is you know California December
nights you a real December nineteenth
that's going to tell the tale right
there so cubes need listen to album and
don't know all about growing
south central is yeah they gonna know
how it affect me yeah right on um you
know why traffic for Nia white-collar
tribe for Nia because that's where like
I stay that's where I'm from and that's
what I wanted to represent with this
project to let people see another side
of me and wanted to tell another telling
my youtube like so many people used to
the dance in and all that and people
don't know this other side so I wanted
to tell another tale it's like a
timeline you know like I was saying with
YouTube like right now I'm going through
it's a trap for Nia stage so people
going to like after this I may go
through something else then one day
somebody gonna look back at all of that
like dang this dude is really on the
road to be left man right right you know
some of the most famous rappers in the
world have come from South Central come
from the west coast in LA you know what
is trap on you're going to bring that we
haven't seen before from other rappers
to tell a story of you know south
central oh it's gonna be unique very
unique because I'm a different artist
and I'm coming from the heart and just
doing my thing it's going to be
different do you have a favorite track
right now off track for Nia that you
know you really are happy with it you
really you know yeah grind till we reach
is this song called grind till we rich
it's a big song it's like real
motivational like because living in
south central it's only a light people
feel like this is like like you could
become a victim of the ghetto that's how
I feel like it's dangerous over there
like all I ears helicopters every night
on a real like but this song cry until
we rich it's real motivational it's like
letting people know like you got to do
what you gotta do to be successful like
if you play football play football give
a char if you rap rap you know if you go
to school if you want to be a doctor you
gotta grind you know right
bronte you rich yeah so you not Nestle
it's your family you're not necessarily
referring to just wrapping your know
everything yeah so it's kind of a
motivational songs yeah you got a grime
and that's what it is grown yeah
absolutely you know um are there any you
know doesn't have to be wrapped but are
there any specific musicians or styled
music that you were really inspired by
would trap for Nia uh gucci mane i like
gucci mane a lot man yeah he got it he
gonna blew up you know in a short period
of time but he was grinding for a really
yeah and no 22 you go watch his youtube
clips and you'll see like dang he's been
grinding you know with with gucci he's
kind of a he's kind of a personality
does dude does that make you like him
more or less this crazy personality nah
I like his music I feel like he's real
challenge it like behind all of that
once you hear songs like his flow as
crazy as delivered he really not to do
his music uh you know there's kind of
this new style of hip-hop coming in
right now you know there's this like he
says gucci mane flow there's this
Trindad flow you know there's there's
this waka flocka flame float it's this
new kind of flow MGK do you think that's
going to be dominating hip hop for a
long time or do you think it's gonna
change your new style oh oh no I feel
like it's just for now like I don't know
I really don't get caught into that I
just try to rap on any beat I like like
I'll put out a diamonds freestyle and
that Ghanim style I did that beat like I
really don't get caught into one style
so I'm gonna next you what do you think
you know people say that the Golden Age
of hip-hop was then i use you know yeah
98 you know late 80s and early 90s and
the period Tupac or biggie you had you
know all these people easy they said
yeah that was the Golden Age it was
about gangsta rap it was just gangster
rap you know now 2012 a lot of its kind
of dancey and more focused towards a of
mainstream audience on do you think
that's a good move for hip-hop where do
you think it should have stayed kind of
more ganks they're a little more
inaccessible to
world now I felt like that's a good move
because it's helping people to become
rich and become successful like it's
like we get a call them media it's
opening doors for other things like just
awful rapping I could probably be an
actor now and I could probably take
photos be a model now like it's opening
doors for other stuff softer like
hip-hop is that a good point right now
right absolutely it's like Kanye you
know he started producing and rapping
now he's got everything you know your
own fashion he's doing you know some
movie stuff doing writing he's doing
always think so he's kind of this
hip-hop Renaissance man y'all can do
everything smooth dogs too yeah he's got
everything many does everything you know
a lot of hip hop right now is becoming
more personal where people are telling
personal stories you know back in the
80s and 90s it was about you know the
hard things that people don't interview
it was just about you know being a cop
killers yeah people are headed now you
know you get people like let's say Drake
or you know Kendrick Lamar has that new
album out and it's really personal it's
like reading that person's diary yeah is
that kind of how you approach your rap
you are you afraid to tell people
everything or you keep some things kind
of hidden sometimes I keep things hidden
because I feel like it's not that time
yet like I gotta I can't let them hear
ya but you know I'm building up to it
and they grown wedding I think people
are growing with you know absolutely see
suit but you at some point you're gonna
let people know that story that was
personal look into your life like I'm
building up to it right of course and so
I guess you know last question is if you
can sum up trap for Nia one sentence
what would that sentence if you could
sell one sentence
that's gonna take a little time don't
worry about turn all your dreams into
reality disappoint you good and I think
you've your Twitter handle tattooed on
your arm don't you Sam like 69 good
thanks so much for talking with us
alright thanks I appreciate it bring
light to the money never slow mo no
shirt cuz I'm Teddy like a cholo and of
course I make your brain and you just
watch okay I got game like eggs in the
club and a steak turn down